الى العراق كمان العراق في ثلوج وجمال
ازائر الابيض زار كردستان حيث غطت الثلوج
مع بدايه موسم الثلوج القمم الجبليه
الشاهقه ومباشره دارت عجلت سياحه الشتويه
في اقليم كردستان اصبحت المنتجعات
والمواقع السياحيه مقصدا للالاف من السياح
العراقيين القادمين من سعر محافظات البلاد
الاستمتاع بمنظر الثلوج غير المالوف في
مناطقه
[موسيقى]
ومن بلده حاج عمران في اربيل ينضم الينا
مراسل صباح العربيه احمد الحمداني وحضور
شخصيا في هذا المشهد الجميل الابيض يا
احمد منورنا اهلا بك صباح العربيه زمان
عنك في هذا المشهد الجميل
[ضحك]
صباح الخير
الزهر الابيض طبعا بالفعل هو الذي يغطي
الجبال يقين كردستان
شكله يا احمد الشمس القويه مش الثلج القوي
ساترك الكاميرا
لتشاهدين طبعا لا تزال او ما تزال حتى
الان ااا طبعا صحيح ان ال موجه ال ال
الثلوج تاخرت تساقط الثلوج تاخر عن عن عن
موعده
بثمانيه او تسعه ايام قياسه بالعام الماضي
الا ان اا جبال اقليم كردستان همم طبعا
همم
وتحول لونها الى الابيض نتحدث عن همم جبال
حاج عمران همم جبال حصاره وايضا جبل كوره
جبال سكران جبال كثيره طبعا هنا في اقليم
كردستان او همم طبعا السلطات المحليه عملت
الى فتح طرقات هذا الطريق هو الذي
تشاهدونه فتحته على الفاور في محاوله همم
رباك الحركه صحيح ان هناك كثير من القرى
ما تزال الحركه مشلوله او الحياه متوقفه
الى حد ما فيها بسبب الثلوج قطع الطرقات
الا ان
والان هناك الجهود لفتح هذه الطرقات امام
امام السكان كي لا همم كي لا
تحاصرهم الثلوج همم طبعا هذه الجهود همم
تحتاج الى وقت يومين ثلاثه ايام ربما او
اربع ايام حتى يكون هناك اتمام لفتح
الطرقات بالتالي نتحدث عن بعض القرى التي
هي قد حصر قد حصرها همم حسرها الثلج وان
بعض المناطق قد دفنت بالثلج وبعض السيارات
السياحيه بالكاد تكون قد غطت وقطعت عن
بعضها عن عن عن عن مناطق المحيطه بها طبعا
المتجهات سياحيه تكون في السفاح الجبال
القمم الجبال
وطبعا كان هناك كنت امر عن همم في طرق في
هذه الطرقات كان كثير من منتجعات السياحيه
لا نرى الا همم يعني همم اللون الابيض في
المنازل وكل المناطق حتى اطول الاشجار
بالتالي فان همم مهمه همم عادت او فتح
الطرقات المتجهات السياحيه ايضا تكون على
مانوطه همم السلطات المحليه هنا في
كردستان الذين اعتدوا على ما يبدوا
بالتاقلم مع الجبال ومع ال ال الثلج وايضا
مع التساقط الثلج بصوره متكرره ايضا هنا
اشير الى اننا همم مازلنا في همم امام
موجه جديده من الثلوج ربما تكون خلال 48
ساعه القادمه
ونحن نتابع معكم هذه الصور المباشره من
كردستان وتحديدا من حجه عمران احمد هل من
فعاليات معينه
انشطه معينه يمارسها السياح وحتى
المواطنين في مناطق معينه خصصت
للاستمتاع الثلج
طبعا تزحلق على الجليد والرياضه التي
مشهوره هنا في اقليم كردستان ما ان يكون
طبعا موعد همم
سقوط الثلج حتى يكون هناك استعداد كبير من
الفرق الرياضيه في جبل كورك والجبال اخرى
لكي يستعدوا للممارسه رياضتهم خصوصا ونحن
نتحدث عن تراجع بعض
التغيير المناخي تراجع بعض
التاخير في وقت همم سقوط الثلوج وبالتالي
رياضه تتزحلق على الجليد وايضا السياحه
الشتويه هناك كردستان على وجهها على ما
يبدو لم تنقطع عنها شكرا